it's deja vu all over again Donald
Trump's worst lawyer trademark legal
eagle All Rights Reserved Alina Hava had
a pretty wild time defending her client
in his second defamation trial for
things he said about EEG and Carol which
is weird because she knows where her
strengths are and it's not being a trial
lawyer would you rather be smart or
pretty and I said oh easy pretty I can
fake being smart oh honey no you can't
fake it Trump's former lawyer Joseph
takapa left a br under mysterious
circumstances um I had to follow my
compass and and my compass told me it
was my time there was done so habba was
lead trial Council in Carol part 2 uh
where her lack of experience and general
shadiness were on full display resulting
in an 83.3 million verdict against Trump
so let's unpack the horrible bungling of
this case what it means for Trump and
what happens next now if you already
watched the illegal Eagle video on the
first egene Carol trial and verdict you
might be wondering why why this is
happening again well kids it's because
time is a flat circle and vengeful Gods
won't be satisfied until we recreate
everything about the last two
presidential election Cycles including
Trump bragging about passing a dementia
test yes he did that again yeah you know
they always show you the first one like
a giraffe a tiger or this or that a
whale which one is the whale and it
appears that a $5 million verdict was
not enough to stop Donald Trump from
defaming people to review in 2019 writer
and advice columnist egene Carroll
accused Trump of sexually assaulting her
at a department store uh she wrote a
book about it and after the book was
published then president Trump issued
two statements accusing her of making it
all up Carol sued Trump for defamation
saying that his comments ruined her
reputation damaged her career in quote
resulted in a slew of insults and
threatening messages emails and comments
to her social media accounts the lawsuit
stalled in federal court because the
Department of Justice then led by Bill
bar included that Trump made his remarks
in His official capacity as president
and he was therefore immune from that
lawsuit but although Trump may be smart
enough to correctly identify a whale he
he was not smart enough to stop talking
about Carol and take the win after he
lost the election Trump continued to
trash talk Carol so she sued him again
in 2022 this time for remarks he made
after he was no longer president uh she
also added a sexual assault claim and
when that case went to trial last year a
jury found Trump liable for assault and
defamation you can check out the first
video that we did on that and the more
than $5 million verdict that she
received in 2023 the justice department
dropped its opposition to the original
defamation lawsuit clearing it to move
forward basically Trump repeated the
same statements so the government
concluded that they could not have been
part of his job as president which was
otherwise giving him immunity uh New
York also passed a law that allowed some
previously time barred sexual assault
claims to go forward and this is why the
first trial was technically called Carol
2 and the second trial is part of the
Carol one case regarding the uh during
presidential statements and since there
was a prior verdict on the merits those
facts and legal conclusions are
established for all time including
spoiler other cases like this and in
2023 the justice department dropped his
opposition I to the original defamation
lawsuit clearing it to move forward
judge Le Kaplan who presided over the
first trial ruled that as a matter of
law Trump defamed Carol because of the
2023 verdict so there's only one issue
in the second trial whether Carol
suffered damages when Trump defamed her
in 2019 while he was President uh
Trump's usual defenses I never knew her
she didn't even go here were off limits
for this trial because liability had
already been determined in the other
case hba's job was to prove that Carol
didn't suffer any damages because of
Trump's defamatory statements so uh how
did she do well I'm glad you asked
things actually got off to a rocky start
when Trump's main lawyer Joe takapa
withdrew from the case takapa is a
season trial lawyer and habba is not
habba might be an okay transactional
lawyer although frankly we have some
evidence that she was extremely
underhanded in that role and should be
disbarred and frankly wasn't even good
at it to begin with but she's definitely
not experienced in federal trial
practice and she was facing off against
Carol's lawyer Roberta Kaplan who has
won landmark cases at the Supreme Court
now you might recall in the the first
trial Trump was only required to pay $5
million now usually it's hard to run a
natural experiment to see what would
happen with a better lawyer uh well this
isn't exactly Apples to Apples but it's
close and it appears that a better
lawyer is worth at least $78 million but
the controversy began when Trump's
mother-in-law passed away a week before
the trial was scheduled to start Trump
did what every devoted husband would do
in the situation he used the death to
try to delay one of his trials hobba
said that Trump would be traveling to
the funeral on the same day the trial
was scheduled to start January 17 and
therefore that he should get a onewe
delay judge Kaplan offered his
condolences but denied the request
saying that quote the defendant is free
to attend the funeral the trial or both
in a footnote judge Kaplan wrote quote
the court subsequently learned that Mr
Trump has scheduled a campaign
appearance at 7 p.m. on Wednesday
January 17th 2024 in Portsmouth New
Hampshire so that's basically judge
speak for I know you were lying when you
previously represented to me and despite
his prior acting experience Trump had
difficulty pulling off the role of
grieving husband now I'll note again
that it's very dumb that federal courts
often don't allow video and that this
trial was not allowed to be televised so
a huge shout out once again to Matthew
Russell Lee at the Inner City Press who
basically live tweeted the whole thing
but it's also possible that not all the
Nuance was captured so take these Live
accounts with a grain of salt now you
might think that the delay issue was
settled after the judges ruling but
that's only because you're not thinking
like Alina habba on the first day of
trial habba asked the judge to postpone
the trial and judge Kaplan said quote
the application is denied I will hear no
further argument on it now when a judge
tells you he's done hearing an argument
he is really done and you should
probably shut up at that point but not
if you Alina Haba uh she tried to make
the same motion and Kaplan Cut Her Off
stating quote none do you understand
that word sit down hoba fired back quote
I don't like to be spoken to that way
your honor she asked to delay again and
he said it's denied sit down it's stuff
like this that Alina Haba would later
refer to when she said that she was not
allowed to speak and courton was told
what to say uh yeah you're allowed to
make an argument just not over and over
and over again now after the jury was
selected eled in trial got underway
habba struggled with applying the Rules
of Evidence to get her exhibits admitted
when habba was cross-examining Carol she
said quote many people called you a liar
before the president made his statement
predictably Robbie Kaplan objected on
the grounds that habba was making a
statement not asking a question habba
then said well quote I wasn't finished
it says here you're a pathetic old hag
uh the it was a document that had yet to
be admitted into evidence so judge
Kaplan stopped habba from continuing
quote no we are not going to read out
loud a document that is not yet in
evidence we're going to take a break
right here to 3:30 and you are going to
refresh your memory about how you get a
document in this is so so bad it's the
equivalent of a teacher saying you know
you're getting a timeout and think about
what you did write the federal Rules of
Evidence 10 times on the Blackboard but
an exhibit is a document or object
that's used by either side in lawsuit to
prove a claim now you don't just get to
pull out a document and ask a witness to
look at it first you have to show the
exhibit to the other party the other
lawyer then generally you need a witness
to testify about the exhibit to
demonstrate that it's authentic and
relevant to the issues at stake uh and
this is known as you know laying the
foundation for an exhibit and usually a
lawyer then ask the judge may I approach
the witness to show them the document
and once you've identified the exhibit
and laid the foundation you ask the
judge to admit it into evidence uh then
you can ask specific questions about
what's inside of the document but Haba
didn't know how to do this and things
got so bad that judge Kaplan started
telling habba how to admit her evidence
step by excruciating step and when Carol
was on the witness stand the judge said
quote show it to her ask her if she
recognizes it habba did that but she
hadn't labeled the document judge Kaplan
said uh it should be marked do it
appropriately do it overnight they need
to be pre-marked and this is extremely
standard practice uh even before
evidence is admitted you need to know
how to reference it it's so basic it's
so embarrassing that I just want to hide
under my desk here and it's not like a
lawyer has to guess what the judges
rules are all judges have standing
orders to cover how they run their
courtroom judge kaplan's standing order
states that he requires his exhibits to
be pre-marked C page 7 which states
quote documents to be offered as
exhibits shall not be attached to
witness statements but shall be
pre-marked and exchanged along with
other proposed exhibits in the usual
fashion now if you've ever been sued for
defamation you'll want a good lawyer not
Alina Haba but if you want a great
lawyer my firm the eagle team can help
if you've been in a car crash suffer
from sexual harassment or were in a data
breach and got one of those data breach
letters we can represent you or help
find you the right attorney who can it's
so important to talk to a lawyer right
away so you don't lose your chance for a
full recovery and maximize your options
so just click on the link in the
description for a free consultation with
my team because you don't just need a
legal team you need the eagle team so
click on the link below but these
mistakes are inexcusable not just
because they're so basic but because if
you don't know how to do this stuff a
learn it's not that hard and B you don't
need to be the only attorney you can
hire local counsel who knows the local
rules or at least knows how to try a
case not everyone is a trial lawyer
that's okay just get help but not
everything that went wrong was hba's
fault in her defense she does have
potentially the world's worst client
Trump repeatedly spoke while Carol was
testifying that's not permitted
reporters heard Trump saying quote it's
a Witch Hunt and it really is a con job
judge Kaplan excused the jury from the
room and then said quot Mr Trump I hope
I don't have to consider excluding you
from The Trial I understand you're
probably very eager for me to do that
Trump responded quote I would love it
this provoked judge Kaplan to say quote
I know you would you just can't control
yourself in these circumstances
apparently Trump shot back you can't
either so this is probably why it was
reported that Joseph takapa told Trump
not to go near the courtroom uh before
he unceremoniously left the legal team
but H's trial work didn't get any better
she allegedly came down with covid-19
right before it was time for her to
present her case Haba said that her
parents were sick with covid and she had
a fever judge Kaplan did Grant her
request to delay the trial until she got
better uh but the illness just happened
to coincide with the New Hampshire
primary which Trump won habba was then
caught partying at a trump Suare in the
granite state here she is posing with
Trump Stafford Dylan quadrucci uh the
Trump campaign kicked quadrucci out of
the event because he posted the selfie
he took with her this is how they treat
loyalty in Trump world I've done nothing
but be extremely loyal to this man and
they kick me out so maybe now he'll
switch from the Republican party to the
leopards eating people's faces party but
the fake sckout delayed the day that
Trump would finally take the witness
stand and when it finally happened judge
Kaplan placed strict limits on his
testimony since there had already been a
trial on liability and Trump waved his
right to testify and during that trial
Joe takapa told the judge that Trump had
waved his right to testify and was
resting his case judge Kaplan then had
to break the news to tupina that his
client who was hanging out on a golf
course in Ireland had just told the
press that he was jetting back to New
York to testify I have to go back for a
woman that made a false accusation about
me of course Trump never showed up but
this time around Trump was in the
building however as the judge said quote
it is a very wellestablished legal
principle in the country that prevents
doovers by disappointed litigant and
he's right this is called collateral
estole it's the legal doctrine that
prevents a party from retiga an issue
that was resolved in a prior lawsuit so
in light of that the judge asked habba
what Trump would testify about uh this
is also an extremely standard thing
although that hasn't stopped L A Haba
from complaining about it it's called a
profer if there's a question about the
suitability or admissibility of
testimony you can ask the lawyer to
profer what is going to be said to make
sure and hob answered quote that he
stands behind his deposition I'll ask
about his State of Mind he'll say he was
defending himself now the judge did give
her the benefit of the doubt but having
Trump reaffirm his deposition testimony
wasn't the best idea as New York lawyer
Michel epner correctly explained quote
it is actually going to be
counterproductive the jury is going to
be instructed that the answers Trump
gave during the deposition were not just
false but knowingly false and made with
actual malice which was required for the
prior verdict reaffirming those answers
will support punitives in fact Mitchell
leer did a 1our interview with Liz D
about this case over at lizz's new
podcast at law and Chaos pod.com I
highly recommend you check it out during
this exchange Trump started yelling from
the gallery quot I wasn't at the trial I
never met this woman this pissed off
judge Kaplan quot Mr Trump keep your
voice down he asked habba for assurances
that her client would abide by his
instructions habba said she quote didn't
have a crystal ball about what he would
do judge Kaplan told habba that she
could ask Trump if he stood by his
deposition testimony habba balk saying
she needed to ask Trump what his
intentions were when he made the
defamatory statements judge Kaplan said
that the topic was off limits quote I
will decide what he has a right to do
here that's my job not yours judge
Kaplan told habba not to ask Trump an
open-ended question warning her that
quote if you ask it there is likely to
be an objection and I'm likely to
sustain it with that settled Trump
started talking loudly again and as
NBC's ktie Fang reported Trump says out
loud in court before the jury is brought
back in I don't know who this woman is
never met this woman judge Kaplan warned
him Mr Trump keep your voice down you're
interrupting these proceedings while
your council is talking and that is not
permitted when the jury re-entered the
courtroom Hab announced she's calling
president Donald Trump uh to the witness
stand but this got under judge kaplan's
skin and Trump immediately did what the
judge warned him not to do contest the
substance of the allegations that he
sexually assaulted Carol right out of
the gate habba asks do you deny these
allegations and Trump says I consider it
a false accusation and the testimony was
stricken remember all this was already
established as a matter of law in the
first trial the testimony was stricken
because the merits of the case were
already decided in the first case
collateral stopple is quite a big issue
Papa also asked did you ever instruct
went to hurt Miss Carol Trump said I
just wanted to defend myself my family
and frankly the presidency on
cross-examination Roberta Kaplan asked
if this was the only trial that he
attended and he said yes and she had no
further questions and as lawyer ronato
marotti points out this was a smart move
quote any question she asked would give
him an opportunity to Riff on irrelevant
subjects and get his story out in front
of the jury which he and his lawyer
haven't done well otherwise now on the
last day of trial habba and her client
were late to court things got worse when
habba and her co-counsel tried to show
the jury a slide of tweets that had had
not been admitted into evidence uh judge
Kaplan told Hava quote you are on the
verge of spending some time in the
lockup now sit down see Carol steam had
apparently agreed to stipulate to let
those Tweets in but Hava had forgotten
to put that into evidence during the
actual trial again even if the other
side agrees you still have to lay the
foundation and admit it into evidence I
think anyone that has seen any Random
episode of Law and Order would know this
uh during closing habba claimed that
Trump was being denied his
constitutional rights quote ladies and
gentlemen in our country you have a
constitutional right to speak Kaplan
smed that down saying you have a
constitutional right to do some kinds of
speech and not others Papa questioned
whether Trump knew Carol and whether he
actually assaulted her when judge Kaplan
reminded the jury that it's been
established that Carol told the truth
about Trump sexually assaulting her HBA
Snapback saying quote it is established
by a jury judge Kaplan said it is
established and you will not quarrel
with me you will finish your statement
Haba also tried her hand at comedy
telling the jury that Carol wasn't the
only person in America who got death
threats on Twitter quote ladies and
gentlemen I received three this week
alone that's me on a good day not
surprisingly judge Kaplan told her she
was out of line and struck that remark
again closing arguments rely on the
evidence that was admitted into court uh
you can't just talk about random stuff
that happened to you but again all this
is supposed to relate only to damage it
so Haba was on slightly stronger ground
when she told the jury that Carol's life
was better after the defamation quote
she's enjoying this let's not forget the
fact that Miss Carol is making more
money now than in 2019 when she brought
this up on the other hand as Carol
lawyer put it quote Donald Trump acts as
if these rules of law just don't apply
to him that touched a nerve with Trump
who got up and stormed out of the
courtroom when Trump's quasi lawyer
Boris epin tried to run after him the
judge said no one else at the defense
Council table was allowed to leave quote
that includes you Mr epin Carol used
evidence of Trump's wealth from the New
York attorney general case where he's
desperately trying to show that he has a
lot of money uh so probably in an effort
to avoid prejudicing himself in that
case Trump didn't really dispute any of
that evidence which helped Carol
establish that the pun of d damages
needed to be actually incentivize him to
stop his conduct Carol's lawyers told
the jurors that Trump will continue to
defame Carol quote unless you make it
stop they showed the jury two videos of
trump making jokes about Carol the first
was just hours after the first verdict
uh the second happened at a CNN Town
Hall the day after the verdict where
Trump's Carol is an ugly liar routine
got big laughs from the audience I have
no idea who the hell she's a whack job
you you did so Carol's attorneys asked
for $12 million to repair her reputation
and at a minimum of $12 million for
emotional harm uh these are compensatory
damages Carol also asked the jury to
award punitive damages punitive damages
are only allowable when there's a high
degree of intentionality and moral
turpitude and the goal of punitive
damages is to deter the defendant from
engaging in similar conduct in the
future and we already know that Trump
finds it difficult n impossible not to
engage in similar conduct because he
defamed Carol right after the first
Carol trial and was tweeting about her
the night before closing arguments so
not surprisingly the jury awarded Carol
7.3 million in compensatory damages for
emot harm $11 million to cover the cost
of a media campaign to restore her
reputation and $65 million in punitive
damages but Trump didn't present an
opposing expert to dispute the amount
that it would take to repair Carol's
reputation which is probably something
that you'd want to do in it damages only
trial and you can see that instead of
signing the verdict form the jurors are
listed by number that's because judge
Kaplan decided that the jury should be
anonymous for their own personal safety
and before he dismissed them for the
last time the judge said quote my advice
to you is that you never disclose that
you were on this jury now Trump wasn't
present when the verdict was read he
left the courthouse 20 minutes
beforehand evidently choosing not to be
on hand for the humiliating verdict it's
likely that Trump will appeal the
Supreme Court has held that punitive
damages violated du Process Clause if
the amount is grossly excessive and
what's grossly excessive is Up For
Debate in a case that involves State
Farm Insurance a jury awarded the plaint
of $1 million in compensatory damages
and $145 million in punitives and the
Supreme Court said that that was
excessive because it was neither
reasonable nor proportionate to the
wrong committed by the defendant so a
ratio of of 145 to1 was just too high
and in 1996 in a case called BMW versus
Gore the Supreme Court created three
factors to determine whether to uphold a
punitive damages award one the degree of
reprehensibility of the defendant's
conduct two the ratio of punitive
damages to compensatory damages and
usually a singled digit multiplier is
allowable and three comparing sanctions
that have been imposed for comparable
misconduct and here the punitive damages
are actually likely to hold up the ratio
of punitives to compensatory damages is
about 3.5x and everyone is assuming that
Trump will appeal and he might but to
stay the execution of the Judgment that
is to prevent Carol from immediately
collecting from Trump he would need to
post a bond now generally in the
southern district of New York you need
to post 110% of the value of the
judgment and usually you would go to a
bond company and have them post it you
would pay the bond company a very small
fraction of the bond value and they post
the bond the bond company gets to keep
about 1% but the weird thing is that in
the first Carol trial Trump posted the
bond in cash he paid the full amount
directly to the court now his lawyers
said that that was to avoid the 1% Bond
fee or about $55,000 on a $5 million
Bond but it's also possible that no bond
company was actually willing to work
with him and who knows what's going to
happen here but if he doesn't post the
bond then Carol can start enforcing the
Judgment by seizing Trump's assets and
putting leans on his property which
would be especially bad for Trump
because many of his assets are public
and well known making them a lot easier
to seize and hobb's bad lawyering may
also come back to bite Trump on appeal
as well because she often let in
evidence without objection and fumbled
so many of the issues she likely didn't
preserve a lot of the otherwise
appealable issues generally you need to
make your argument in the trial court
and preserve issues in the trial court
to be allowed to bring those issues up
on appeal and if you don't you wave
those issues anyway hire competent
Council kids but the big question is
whether this verdict will actually stop
Trump from ranting about Carol but as
Ellie Mall points out in Trump's first
comments after the verdict he
specifically did not mention Carol by
name so maybe punitive do work but right
now Alina Haba probably just wants to
disappear from the face of the planet
luckily today's sponsor incog can help
because incog removes your personal data
from online data Brokers to help you
stay private they'll reach out to make
sure it's taken down and if these data
Brokers object which I've seen in my
case incog will take care of that too
and make sure that they take it down
have you been getting a ton of spam
emails calls and texts I know I have and
it's probably in part because online
data Brokers have your data and sell it
to unscrupulous advertisers now I don't
know if you've ever Googled yourself but
there are major people's search sites
that probably have your personal contact
info it might be because of a data hack
but sometimes our friends and family
even provide that information
voluntarily by clicking on one of those
boxes when they sign up for a website or
an app these sites provide in-depth
records including information like your
home address contact details license
plate numbers family members financial
information and even religious and
political affiliation these sites can
expose you to a wide range of dangers
from scams to identity theft to online
harassment and stalking and it was
really important to me that I not be on
those sites and incog took that
information down and not only does incog
stop marketing efforts but it also
reduces your risk of information being
part of a data breach or use an identity
theft or stocking that you really don't
want to take a chance with but if you
have been in a data breach please let me
know uh but data Brokers are required to
remove your personal information from
their database if you ask them to but
tackling this by yourself would be
nearly impossible but that's where incog
comes in incog fights on your behalf to
remove your personal data from Brokers
and deals with any objections on their
side all you have to do is create an
account and give them approval to work
on your behalf incog conducts repeated
ongoing removals because even if the
data broker removes your data once they
can collect it again and use it again
incog makes sure that your personal
information stays off the market for
good here's my personal incog dashboard
it showed me that these three sites had
data on me that was rated 10 out of 10
on incog sensitivity scale these Brokers
had data including my contacts financial
data and Health Data it was terrifying
to see exactly how many Brokers had my
data but it's really fun to watch incog
get them to delete that info one by one
so if online privacy is important to you
give incog a try click on the link below
to get 60% off incog when you use the
code legal eagle again to get an
exclusive 60% off discount just click on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description and use the code
legal eagle after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court